bene tutti ragazzi proprio questo
nuovissimo meraviglioso e mirabolante
video dove faccio fuori teheran i grossi
così sono molto contento di fare questo
lavoro
cominciamo a chiede due file abbiamo
fatto ragazzi il primo contatto incontri
ravvicinati e manca lavori domestici che
sono da parte della cucina chi non vuole
vedere una tarantola così nel forno e io
non lo voglio vedere che emerga un che
ragazzi vediamo se riusciamo a fare una
partita decente
il bello che la lista degli obietti la
cosa vera rischio è che la lista degli
obiettivi ti permette di tirare schiaffi
mimetico di mer a posto tutto a posto
tutto a posto
non mi sento in condizione di fare
questa con della lavastoviglie non ci
sono dai nella vostra idea mi rifiuto di
tutor in credono che la vostra ci sia
roba no perché la usi fini non più
chiude la lavastoviglie per il anzitutto
nel frigo se c'è qualcosa li do fuoco
vabbè anzi facciamo così guarda a
prescindere ho fatto fuori della roba
senza sapere che c'era veniamo voglio
neanche sapere guarda ti chiudi frigo tv
brigo perfetto tutto risolto anche nel
freezer ecco è morta e mora sono morti e
ranieri ci godo tantissimo ma io non
posso dare una scocca di fuoco a tutto
tipo cosino da un po di foto a tutti in
qualche modo la tata roma prende foto
quindi teoricamente lo riuscito di lo
stesso
io non voglio neanche vedere cosa c'è in
giro nido poco e basta perfetto perfetto
tutto ok tutto che vai a poco tranquillo
zidane tomori chiamatemi album quando
avete al telefono 335 15 26 62 40 lo
sono inventato e venite pure
tranquillamente rame che schepp ha dove
kato dove caso non l'ho beccato al
mercato l'ho beccato peccato peccato che
tipo era quella
volevo fisico non so cosa fa quello non
so se kakà figli o robe progetto sta
diventando veramente peggio di uno di
quelli noi senigallia perché
effettivamente se quel regno arancione
credo di aver capito che diversamente
dagli altri chi si lancia addosso quella
la sua particolarità
perché un okaka figli questo ci si
lancia addosso teoricamente tutto a
posto territoriali e morì storicamente
si è trasformato voi non il gioco pieno
di juncker che non è che mi renda
proprio orgoglioso di giocarci però ok è
tutto a posto quanti non sono ovviamente
spendendo poco tutto ho dato una padella
e una nuova arma per lucini anni penso
di faccia fuori istantaneamente che ha
proprio questa li fa fuori
istantaneamente mega utile fantantonio
gragnanella che schifo o addio
che schifo dice rocco imbarazzate veloso
lai brucia no ragazzi orribile cioè il
ragno gigante scritti si lancia in
faccia veramente pesante starò la
madonna di dio mori è morto ma no no no
no io non posso giocarci ve lo dico
questo è l'ultimo ebrei dove aver fatto
veramente tutto sono orgoglioso di me
stesso ci ho messo un'ora e mezza ma ne
va dentro
mandiamo nell'altra stanza a vedere se
effettivamente è rimasto qualcosa allo
ragazzi eccola e sono i ragni e in etici
brutti come la fame c'è nel senso li
vedi solo quando riesci a bussare
attenzione
perfetto
morite notai lo peccato questo regalo
questo l'ho beccato tantissima cosa
santo it io ok ho bruciato un po tutti
un po tutti quelli che c'erano anche la
dietro c'è gente veneto bruciamo tutto
sede a malta o bruciato tutto giusto che
certi un ragno vivo la goduria è anche
questo andiamo al prossimo livello
ragazzi usciamo di qua per cortesia che
sente un gioco finale de silva
il modulo si ma che cacchio ma ebraica
fanno uscire a staccata del demonio
mamma mia che joe con fame queste sono
quelle della demo dai a saperlo avrei
fatto
va bene allora proviamo a riaprire ma
vedere se ne sta a finire quella
dell'altro
non so se comprarlo e senza come parlare
di episodi veramente mi sentirei vado
contro le mie aspettative di vita
browser per non aver proviamoci voglio
vedere se riesco a fare fuori tutti con
questa roba del fatto che riesco andare
a mandare a fuoco le cose ancora prima
quindi a prescindere sfondo a un pò qua
tipo qua
secondo me sta roba m gaudì le ragazze
che anche senza che li vedi muoiono
quindi utilissimo quando a poco tutti
gli oggetti
devo assolutamente provare ragazzi
fucile a pompa
mi interessa tantissimo mi interessa più
come la mia gioia voglio provare a usare
fucile a pompa perché non me l'ha fatto
equipaggiare più ma anche la pentola
sono cose che ciò sono alimentari voglio
provarci ragazzi ciao ragazzo dove che
sei
dov'è il ragazzo requa dove vi sento
vita eccolo qua a posto meraviglioso
diamo fuoco alle cose con calma senza
problemi come sempre lo sapremo quando
apriamo un po tutto abbiamo fatto un
lavapiatti obiettivo un figlio
santissimo benedetto tipo salve
arrivederci si curavano fatti fuori
subito santi saltano in faccia non è
proprio il massimo che non è morto oddio
non muore
highlander
ok a posto che adesso posso dare fuoco a
tutto effettivamente questo rumore
bruttissimo 321 via il frigo via le cose
sopra frigo e alle 9 sotto il frigo per
opel bianco via tutto la casa a scuola
completamente a casa riusciamo a casa
dal pd se ne frega la casa del genere
non merita l'esistenza perfetto tutto
qua meraviglio è così che si gioca sul
gioco ragazzi è così che si gioca quanto
ed io ho rifatto comunque lo sto
rifacendo ragazzi ma preciso perché
volevo provare a farli fuori in modo
decente
lo prova a farla in meno tempo passa di
qua allora posso anche provare a mettere
la roba tutto a posto dai proviamo a
fare solo l'ultima roba questa che non
aveva fatto mettere tutto a posto che se
effettivamente l'abbiamo fianco con le
robe per bene tutto per bene se ne frega
[Musica]
fantastico tutto al fuoco anche qua
perfetto questa è l'essenza di questo
gioco ragazzi questa è l'essenza di
giugno dovrei aver fatto tutto raga sono
veramente orgoglioso del mio lavoro e di
me stesso il momento di posizione degli
oggetti allora 1 2 o 3 4 vediamo se
riesco a mettere gli occhi a posto
stavolta ragazzi nota mi serve perché
voglio vedere cosa succede taglierino
martello non li riconoscono e anche tra
l'altro sono tutti bruciati ragazzi sono
due miliardi di oggetti ma non li vedo
proprio l'unc in giro io quel problema
mancano dei cacciaviti chiavi inglesi un
martello e una spatola la spatola sta
qua però non è neanche questa non me la
prende ho dato martellino nice spaccare
le cose che dove ci sono i ragni e il
mio lavoro effettivamente quindi niente
di male che mancano due oggetti che non
ho idea di cosa siano ha eccola qua
perfetto trovata tutto a posto
organizza gli attrezzi sono stato un
fenomeno mi manca a possa aprire la
festa del dio possa aprire a far sapere
la lazio
solette in gel potenziamento sbloccato
questa di sono molto proud e nei giochi
del genere io me la cavo
ragazzi ho fatto un po di allora questa
è casa mia dopo aver scoperto che ci
sono dei ragni perfetto ho fatto un buon
disastro per quello che aveva questo
aveva fatto effettivamente io non ho
raggiunto così è giusto così ragazzi si
gioca contro i ragni questo è quello che
io vorrei fare a casa mia nipote
notturno per almeno nei giochi dove
viene sia piaciuto fateci sapere se
volete che compri questa roba perché si
può anche comprare con gli altri livelli
sarei molto piero riportato studio erano
solite meno dei commenti
per adesso quando vado a farmi una
doccia che mi sento tutto sento un po di
schifo addosso i giochi la doccia per
bene vediamo forse episodio ragazzi
grazie va verso il profilo chiede al
canale e sanzionati come schiacciare
insetti guardate anche livido prima ora
ci vediamo così bella ragazza
[Musica]